le rouge et le noir de stendhal une
oeuvre incontournable pour ces lycéens
qui à rennes est en terminale elle a
choisi le s'inscrire aux cours de
l'association archimède pour réviser la
littérature pendant les vacances j'ai
pas eu un bac l'année dernière du coup
bas quand j'ai pris ce natif de prendre
des cours parce que je repasse le
français du coup impérativement que ce
soit au niveau
en plus c'est des petits groupes se
déroule de 3,4
on n'ose pas des groupes de rock comme
aux classes ou et ses avocats français
archi bénéfique le soutien scolaire est
assuré par des professeurs des
mathématiques aux langues vivantes
depuis 1990 l'équipe propose un suivi
hebdomadaire ou des stages vacances
comme ici pour la toussaint
une quarantaine d'élèves se sont
inscrits tous niveaux confondus
donc il faut en gros toute la matinée ça
peut être mal français ça peut être mal
physique ça peut être français anglais
enfin bon on essaie de d'avoir une
organisation aussi très saoul ç'a
toujours été depuis le départ de
travailler avec chaque enfant en
fonction de ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire de
ses besoins de le prendre là où il en
est aujourd'hui ces lacunes c'est et de
de construire à partir de sa dynamique
propre
là j'ai pris anglais est à vendre pour
moi est vacant et les grandes vacances
j'avais pris français enlevés aussi ça
permet de réviser pour nous les vacances
pour comme ça quand tu quand on reprend
les cours on n'oublie pas ce qu'on avait
fait avant
heil en course et le numérique qui est
privilégié la ville mis sur les
révisions en ligne pour ses élèves du cp
à la terminale le site et l'encours en
ligne propose des cours et des exercices
dans chaque matière un service offert
gratuitement par la mairie depuis 2010
sur présentation d'un justificatif de
domicile
ça le rend beaucoup plus autonome
deuxièmement ça développe sa créativité
et surtout et surtout ça développe sa
confiance en lui-même
vous avez votre progression par exemple
pas si vous avez fait 10 exercices en
histoire ou si vous en avez fait 50
il faut en faire 50 vous avez la montée
vous allez voir si vous avez réussi si
vous avez échoué
vous pouvez recommencer le court au
total 3000 élèves élan courtois sont
abonnés à ce dispositif
le soutien en ligne ou en direct avec
des professeurs peut être un moyen de
lutter contre le décrochage scolaire
chaque année 140 mille élèves quittent
le système scolaire sans aucun diplôme